President Biden kicked off
his truncated visit
to Asia to meet with fellow world
leaders at the G7 summit in Japan.
The leaders of some of the world's
largest economies are expected
to try to keep a sharp focus on China's
growing aggression
globally
and on Russia's brutal
war against Ukraine.
But as President
Biden shakes hands
with fellow presidents
and prime ministers,
one American family is urging
President Biden to address
another issue close to their hearts.
They're asking President Biden
to press harder
on Japan's Prime Minister
Fumio Kushida, to release
an American Navy lieutenant
who is in prison in Japan.
Lieutenant, Original Kono
has been
behind bars
in Japan for nearly 300
days, part of his three year sentence
for what Japanese courts
called the, quote,
negligent driving
deaths of two Japanese citizens in May.
20, 21
Lieutenant O'Connor says he suffered
from acute mountain sickness
as he was driving
down from Mount Fuji with his family
and became unconscious behind the wheel.
And that led to the tragic, deadly crash.
Joining us now
for an exclusive interview from
Japan is his wife, Brittany,
our co-owners.
Brittany, good to see you again.
Quickly, if you can remind our viewers
why you think this three year sentence
is unfair, and undeserved
What happened on May 29th?
2021 was absolutely a tragedy.
However, he was mid-conversation
with my daughter
when he lost consciousness.
He couldn't be awoken.
A crash happened back in and wake him.
He did not fall asleep.
He was not negligent.
And so
I understand what happened was a tragedy.
He said from day one,
he wanted to make sure the family
was taken care of.
But he has also maintained
that he was never tired
and he did not fall asleep.
And there is no evidence to suggest
that he did.
So your husband sent you a letter
a couple of weeks ago
that you've shared with us.
I want to read part of it.
It says, I'm not doing that good.
The walls and bars
seem to be making my cell even smaller.
As of late.
I get sick to my stomach
thinking about whether 30 minute meetings
through a window is helping
or hurting the kids. And you.
I feel closer to an animal
than a human being right now.
Just just awful.
Tell us about your reaction
when you read that, if
you would, Brittany
I was heartbroken.
You know,
I've I've been with Reg for 12 years.
He's really good at doing
really hard things, things
that people just don't want to do
without complaint, with a good attitude.
And and to hear his spirit
just kind of breaking
it.
It breaks my heart. And it also.
It makes me mad.
Yeah.
How are your kids
And, you know,
it depends on the day.
But they're hurting,
you know, they
they try to make sense of this.
We talk about it all the time.
But my son asked me the other day,
he said, Mommy, the president
you said the president's
getting daddy home.
And why is me home yet?
And, you know, if
if daddy suffered an emergency
why is he in jail?
And those are questions I can't
I can't answer,
you know,
and my daughter says, Mommy,
I just want to hug daddy.
I can't do anything to fix that.
But they're good natured kids.
They're wonderful.
And, you know,
they're doing the best they can.
So you
you that's a reference, obviously,
to the brief discussion
you had with President Biden
after his State of the Union
speech in February.
He promised you
he wouldn't give up
and you have praised the White House
for engaging with you.
Is the Navy helping at all?
Is the Pentagon
No, absolutely not.
They've they've done nothing
but work against us.
In fact, he's
accused the Pentagon
of conducting a whisper campaign
in an attempt
to convince some people
that your husband, in fact,
got a fair trial in Japan.
And you say that
you even have some emails
that would prove
Pentagon
officials are pushing this narrative
and they're lying.
But you're not going
to release those emails now.
Tell us more about this
You know, we have the
emails outlining the status
of forces agreement violations
that were committed in the investigation.
Letters have been sent out
to members of Congress.
We've gotten a hold of
some of those people,
have given them to us and have said
hey, this is what DOD is saying.
It's not quite in line
with what you're saying.
I've taken those letters into CNN Legal.
Gone over them point
by pointing confirmed
with them that they are false.
And yet these things continue to be said
And I just I do
I understand that
the alliance with Japan is important.
I do not believe that it is so weak
that we need to allow Japan
to unjustly imprison our naval officers
for any actions.
Thank you so much.
Keep speaking out.
Keep talking.
And we're going to keep having you.
We're going
to keep talking about this case.
We really appreciate your time.
Thank you, Jake.